nevada's congressional races this of
course ahead of the big november general
election our eight news now emerson
college the hill poll shows the house
and senate racers are all very
competitive and we've got just four
months to go politics now host john
langler breaks down those numbers
right now in washington democrats hold
the house and have a slim majority in
the senate republicans know there's a
big opportunity though to flip seats and
flip control in the midterms our polling
shows they're not far off the race
getting the most financial and
advertising attention is for senate
democrat catherine cortez masto is
trying to hold on to her seat against
republican challenger and former
attorney general adam laxalt right now
senator cortez masto leads with 44
percent but laxalt isn't far behind at
41 percent nine percent are undecided
unlike some of her democratic colleagues
polling shows miss cortes masto is doing
well with minority voters spencer
kimball's a pollster with emerson
college the question is going to be over
the next couple of months can either the
republicans expand their vote and pick
up some of that minority vote do the
democrats expand some of their voting
recently nevada democratic lawmakers
redrew congressional boundaries their
goal was to spread out enough of their
supporters to keep swing districts safe
right now all three races with
democratic incumbents in southern nevada
are very close in district one incumbent
dina titus holds a four and a half point
lead over republican challenger mark
robertson nearly 17 percent are
undecided in northern nevada's district
two incumbent republican mark amade
leads his challenger by around 11 points
incumbent democrat susie lee leads her
race in district three by just two
points over republican april becker 13
percent are undecided democrat stephen
horsford has a similar lead in his
battle to keep serving district four he
leads sam peters by three points once
again 13 percent are undecided at first
third and fourth was
a gamble that the democrats took to make
the the third and fourth more democrat
in this in the first district a little
bit less we'll see if that pays off in
november it means the efforts by both
parties to flip all five seats will only
increase heading into november john
langler live local now